ramey get us up to speed what is the
latest yeah sure thing Avon basically
right now we're seeing that 73 people
are confirmed to have been killed in
this now what is what everyone is saying
is a terror attack in the French city of
nice in addition to that the nice mayor
now is also saying via twitter that that
truck that was used in this attack was
actually filled with arms as well as
grenades the implication there is that
that attacker at least that single
attacker that we know of so far had more
intent to harm and damage down in the
french riviera city the mayor also says
that this attack is the worst event in
the history of nice now to get you up to
speed the events that we're talking
about happened about two and a half
hours ago down in these where a truck
rammed or continued to ram across a
promenade in these called the promenade
des anglais which is a very popular
place for revelers especially during
today which is of course bastille day
and so basically according to some
reports the truck went as far 700 meters
some other reports say it went as far
has two kilometers so there is the
potential Livan for the death toll and
the injury toll to rise and rainy you
know we are getting more and more
comments from from heads of state around
the world the Canadian Prime Minister
Justin Trudeau tweeting out that
Canadians are shocked by this attack we
know the president here in the US has
been briefed on this event on this
matter so now that it is labeled a
terror attack by the prosecutor's office
how did that change anything at this
point sure Betty in terms of the state
of emergency or the state of alert
admiss here in France basically French
president Francois Hollande has earlier
today actually said that he was going to
lift that state of preparedness that he
started on November 13th of course when
the Bata klein incident happened when
about 130 people were killed but looking
ahead it
as if that potentially is now off the
cards we are waiting for clarification
on that from the French president who is
meeting with the interior ministry now
that expiry was set to happen on july
twenty sixth but potentially because of
course what is happening in this in the
early hours of this morning now here in
france that potentially could change but
of course we'll keep you posted with
that